[Music]
rather than seeing the world in the
immediate aftermath of thanos attack
avengers 4 might take us back to the
marvel cinematic universe
five years into the new status quo is
the latest rumor true
let's break down the possibilities one
possible confirmation of the five-year
time jump rumor
comes thanks to the movie's casting
while scott lang's daughter cassie
has been played thus far by abby ryder
thoughtson in the two ant-man films
the superhero daughter could be growing
up fast suspiciously fast
in april 2018 just before the release of
infinity war
news leaked that marvel had cast a new
actress emma furman as cassie for
avengers 4.
on its own this isn't huge news the mcu
has recast roles before
but furman happens to be seven years
older than a predecessor
in the role that's a big jump all but
confirming that this story plans on
ageing cassie
quickly it's a fairly abrupt shift
considering the younger actress just
played the role in ant-man and the wasp
which takes place during the events of
infinity war if the sequel starts or
avengers 3 left off
then why would they need such an older
performer add in a time jump and it all
makes sense
so what would a five-year gap between
the two avengers sequels mean for the
story
for one thing we'd get a serious look at
how people have adjusted
to half of the universe being gone while
grief can last for a lifetime
five years is a long time to get over
some initial shock
this way would actually see the lasting
effects of the avengers devastating loss
lots of rumors about the movie revolve
around beating thanos with time travel
which sounds like the smart move but
what would the ethical implications be
of erasing years of experience from the
infinity war survivors
years after the universe has begun to
move on it could throw a wrench into the
avengers plans for fixing things
aside from thanos himself the most
important character in infinity war is
arguably tony stark
the movie begins with him and peppa
talking about the future thinking about
having a child
and contemplating retirement but
retirement looks a lot different when
your last battle ends and your biggest
loss
we don't know if peppa survived the snap
but if she did it's possible that the
couple could have moved on from infinity
war by having a child
if the movie starts five years after the
war then tony would face a devastating
decision
what if saving the universe meant giving
up his kid would he really sacrifice his
own flesh and blood
just to pan around with peter parker
again well aunt may maybe
but pete while we really don't know
where avengers 4 is going there have
been enough set leaks to give us some
huge clues for months we've seen photos
of the production
apparently shooting a new version of the
avengers climatic battle of new york
with old costumes and hairstyles on set
further affirming that we've seen some
of this before
how they do it we don't know but unless
marvel is playing 11 dimensional chess
and leaking monumental misdirection
it's almost definitely going to happen
the idea of a five-year time jump adds
some fuel to the time travel argument
after all if the movie involves time
travel then who cares what time it is
when the story starts
it could be 5 years into the future or
50 years and all still end happily on
the same day the infinity war started
think back to the future think
terminator as soon as going back in time
is on the table all the problems of a
time jump can be undone just like that
after sitting out infinity war avengers
4 will finally see the return of clint
barton
but not necessarily hawkeye at this
point it's all but certain that jeremy
renner will be coming back as ronin
a samurai inspired character whose
mantle has been taken up by quite a few
people in the comics
including hawkeye hawkeye sat out
infinity war while living under house
arrest with his loving family
following the events of civil war but
what if thanos's attack destroyed his
family
would the snap make hawkeye snap we
think so and we think it's going to be
awesome
a five-year gap on a family in the
fridge would provide a perfect cover
for the development and re-emergence of
a completely retooled barton after all
the man really just wants to be with his
family right
not only would a time jump give him
space to train in the ways of the
samurai
the loss of his loved ones could also
turn him into a lawless badass with
nothing to lose
back in action as an avenger but for
real now if this is how
it happens he'd need a little time to
develop that new persona
if the five-year rumor is true the
timeline could fit
to us this time jump rumor is pretty
compelling but there's one aspect about
the theory that gives us pause
one thing infinity war lagged during its
two and a half hour run time
was a proper reunion between steve
rogers and tony stark
the last time the two were in the same
room they were more or less trying to
murder each other
and that was way back in 2016 by the
time infinity war rolled around
stark was still reluctant to pick up the
phone and make the call to his friend
from work
by the end of the movie they've both
lost and they still haven't reunited
the problem with a five-year time jump
is simple audiences want to see steve
and tony hug it out
would they really skip such an
anticipated reunion by starting the
movie in the future
or would the two somehow still be
avoiding each other five years later
you can't jump that far into the future
and tell us captain america and iron man
haven't made up yet
can you it's like grow up guys the world
is ruined
have a beer and talk it out it is
possible that the two heroes could avoid
each other for five whole years
or maybe the movie skips ahead five
years later after tony returns to earth
and tony and cap have regrouped one way
or another audiences need that scene
would a time jump really deny it to us
maybe but knowing these movies
it might end up being worth it no matter
how things actually go down
we'll see what happens when avengers 4
lands in 2019